assalamualaikum greedy's a piece have
you heard of the Backstreet Boys what
about uh sure
well what is my next guests have in
common with them he almost signed on the
dotted line almost sold his soul it
would have opened the door where he
would have been touring with the likes
of Usher and the Backstreet Boys because
he had a boy band of his own until he
hooked up with formerly known singer Cat
Stevens you heard of Cat Stevens now
known as Yusuf Islam gave him some
incredible advice and now because of
that advice alhamdulillah he's here on
the D show with us to share his story
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
as
Oh
[Music]
feel this way
lovelies
right we
so how you doing soupy we're here with
soupy former almost on the same circuit
as the Backstreet Boys or were you in
the Backstreet Boys or you're in the
same same management company something
with the Backstreet Boys music many
people do we finally did the same
management group as the Backstreet Boys
before the Backstreet Boys
we were like the first you could say boy
band early 2000 I was coming out of
Australia to take over the world and all
the rest of it Allah Allah Allah has
other plans for me and you know through
you could say short meeting of rusev Tom
Cat Stevens kind of gave me a nudge you
could say and woke me up a little bit
and I looked in amazing ways and he
really he really worked worked it on me
because you know after so many years
trying to get that record deal he came
at the same time he'd everything and I I
had a choice to make
directions ago and as you can see what
so the Backstreet Boys at that time that
was like one direction like what what's
similar to some of the the groups today
they were like the biggest thing
Sciences 3d work yeah and you know one
of the big like and follow you know you
don't know what time you have to market
and you know working so hard you want to
really get that stage
yeah Backstreet Boys were just before we
came out and the management group that
we ended up going with or who now was
pretty much we found out that the same
team as the local no Backstreet Boys
with a non-existent at the moment the
typical boy band or you know they end
off through the depression and breakouts
and now we're seeing some there's what
is the three guys on screen there is
that what one of them is that you are
one of these guys who are like singing
like and as uh what was the name of so
you were also what was the name of your
boy band moves everything you know until
you know because I was being torn
between being famous being in a boy band
just blew me away that I live the nudies
name you know growing up as a kid you
are Muslims like you think wow actually
exist we came once upon a time on the
same earth walking on and being torn
between the two you know performing with
the group and everything and probably
you could say was the the the change
that took me away was during the
[Music]
Sydney casino which is a largest casino
in Sydney we're performing and you know
leave the girls screaming and everything
in the background and I'm just looking
out into the crowd and almost like
everything just stop for a second and
the lights were red and I was just
looking around one minute slark I was in
Hellfire and I just sorta myself okay so
you want to end your life you could drop
it right now it's the people you want to
be raised with you know much about the
same at the time this was the moment I
didn't ever see you know the
pre-contract you know you name it
everything was painful choreography food
clothing and to see Jim and I have to
get out of this contract now so they'll
probably the reason and some of the
other group members were part of the
group that I'd established so they
started asking for the songs right and
everything and you know take whatever
you want just give me a nice group gave
me famous but I thought no as you know
Cat Stevens he missed a lot of money
like many others whose royalties even
when they are much older and they're not
even performing artists get to the point
where they've frustrated me and the
whole group now you were also almost
touring with and I like talking with
people get fascinated with this and I
and it's also very intriguing because to
see someone because most people this is
what they want they want to be with the
stars they want to be a star they want
to become famous so it's very very
ironic for someone now they're looking
and they're like why would you leave
that why would you leave that lifestyle
you're almost touring with Usher you had
actually a few - what is it a couple hit
hit songs that made it mainstream
they're on the mainstream radio and
you're all and you
Simon our experience was enough for me
to have a song before the song we go to
the mainstream radio station number one
[Music]
and I'm gonna read it to them and they
painted again and through that we
started getting calls to support you
guys to support HR least one in
Australia right what should I do so so
the one responsible is
he's drinking his guts out this one
small in cocaine this was now working
Lockett me way from during that time was
drugs and alcohol I just as a sportsman
back in the old days is something I
never let my body exposed just looking
around you people were happy you know
he's complaining about him
these songs complained about the
depression yeah they say you seem on TV
after all nice so the answer these days
unfortunately they are being deceived
when I see these is getting them of
these stars you know on the TV in the
movies okay
you know these children all these youth
you just have a look beyond that you
know silent lights are they would run
far from their life song honestly
because I've had a little taste of that
and it didn't taste good at all and now
what the rule stars would say in my life
now very few people big ones you see
early in the morning
these are the supersize super blow of
budgeting their face you know as youth I
you know spend our life trying to
encourage peace through through the
cartoons in the film due to these are
the Czar's not depressed
you know stars yeah we got we got a lot
of fake stuff out there people being
deceived like you said how old were you
at that time and were you were you
Muslim at the time what what had you
that much grounded like were you at a
crossroads and in life kind of paint the
picture again like how old were you were
you Muslim when did you accept Islam and
what what was the catalyst I had you
finally take off because it takes a lot
of courage it takes a lot
you know to to give up which what was
presented in front of you many people
they sell their souls but you actually
you know and you know completely but but
he's extremely beautiful human being was
he realized who you need to know who I
was
other than the nephew you know the trend
of use and I didn't get to meet him
conversation on the phone and we see
each other I had to go and drop off my
demo CD so you could help me
you know get a record deal but he sent
me a little apologize but in that nail
it was probably a line that changed
everything for me when he basically said
that my religion these words martini Sam
doesn't allow me to assist you to get
into this is what Yusuf Islam is telling
you in the letter yes tell me martyr
legion and you know yours you know at
the time of that no that's what he
saying is true he basically has my
treasure that I had and the rubbish said
he threw out is what I'm just going
through now you know I mean so we
basically swapped you know trash to
treasure so him having his Sam was you
know what woke me up and you know my
mind that you know how he's claiming
he's really June is he saying you know
and it's true he was not my religion so
that's at the time when I came back to
Sydney after working hard to get a
ripple deal and it was right there
waiting and at the same time as I
started reading the book myself and I
put the book down I just ever I went
even in this you know they seem you hope
you just walk around them and you know
thinking what are you reading and I just
said artist biography retirement and I'm
just gonna pull it down I'll just
completely fell in love with Muhammad
SAW Selim you know he basically embalmed
out bolt out of the way all the
superstars to follow and you know the
musicians the stars they don't even come
anywhere close to him as a human being
and that was basically it with with the
tipping point happened and my mission in
life was the world to know about I just
wanted to find it away and and one of
the game today was so bad and and
typically you want to get into the Dean
and you know you're on such a high and
you want to work with everybody wanted
to everybody here and I thought it was a
little bit of disunity she's still
around unfortunately and I decided to
sign up something called one
productions and just stood out just like
movies get into the entertainment field
not knowing anything about you know the
movie industry other than what I saw and
yeah basically through him we'll talk
more about that so Yusuf Islam formerly
Cat Stevens he gave you some advice
pretty much saying that his religion
didn't allow him to help facilitate that
deal that you wanted and that's stuck in
your mind and at the same time you're
looking more into the life of prophet
muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
so Cat Stevens really had a lot to do
with your shift in mindset is that
correct
thank you
[Music]
basically kind of clues thinking was
what school me yes something much bigger
plan for me much better than any Rick
will deal or any anything you could
imagine you know as life saw and that
was when your heart starts getting
attached to Jonah to the real faint to
the real flats and Duma and houses and
reach you want that okay but I'll get
you for eternity and this is where you
start becoming something you really go
out and you know unduly know you know
like I sit through a bit of icing you
say the same through being there in the
worst of places upon a lot like you know
nobody gave me the key day it just came
through that I think of seeing how
unhappy people were you know it seemed
that the depression behind the cameras
you know they were sitting at the bar
you know drinking till they don't even
know who they are you know having to
carry them to their cars and the whole
time I was completely sober so I see you
know what's going on around the year and
you know those few events and you could
say no when the coffin was Muhammad SAW
so then he basically completed her
formula it was just wow now I have a
superstar to to aspire to to follow
someone that you could not find a single
function somebody just fell in love with
without even seen his face this was what
amazed me the most is that so many
people do this a little of the assumable
and yet they have never even seen you
know and despite knowing how he was mean
with the youth how many was with his why
is Harry with the Muslims you know is
it's just you know mind-boggling and for
me in one mission of hamdulillah now is
to firstly try to get just close to his
life so we you know it's a mission in
itself but at the same time hopefully
trying to inspire others and and just
try to see their wife in that kind of
life song because it's it's very
decision at the end
unfortunately it's you know you could
say maybe 15 times worse you know in the
last these things we use back then there
wasn't all phones and you know easy
access yeah it reminds me of when I did
an interview with a former rapper and
one quote stuck in my mind it was by
lune where he said that we were paying
for the disease while the cure was free
so people are paying for everything
that's destroying them while the hidayah
the guidance all they have to do is
sincerely turn to their creator and ask
for the guidance and he'll facilitate
that he sent it but people run away from
purpose and they start following their
desires and you can see like you've seen
it I've seen it and people are just
miserable and then people they look at
them and others have also mentioned how
those two three minute videos are a
deception because they show all of the
material things all of the glitz and
glamour but what goes on for the rest of
the day is a nightmare week's lectures
and documentaries
and he was you know this was to get
access to down material you know
information but the fortunate they don't
know these things you know yeah at the
same time the patients you know always
on another level as well so he is more
you know readily available the lectures
speakers you know I think back then you
could count how many popular speakers in
the world on one hand now there are so
many hundred in that and you know you
know that the social media may be back
in the old days we have to speak all at
the same time yeah so I was going to ask
you if if you remember that we have some
history and I remember you guys had the
best quality material that we can find
and
and you remember we used to have those
uh we go back yeah I was really
passionate about getting those DVDs that
you guys had and and come to the LA and
I and I and I thank you all so you gave
me my my first I think it was Sony Vegas
was it that was a gift from you jaeseok
lied yeah
remember the the software yeah because
you know inspired you because you know
we should be greedy about is rewards yes
and what I see and was the passion that
passionate so you know really days to
keep you know and and you know you've
had and now it's just amazing because
you know some others then later on this
as far as you again so you because you
know you start with intention you find
that you you lost a long time and you
know I think you'd be like ten use now
may be in the den show now how many use
for miss the main ten years from - yeah
from the LA we started back in our 2006
the the program yeah hamdullah Wow
time has flown by you also say you're
you're from Australia and how
we had a recently not too long ago did
you know the brother may Allah grant him
Jenna he was doing some wonderful work
he also changed his life around you
heared these stories I think Ali Bennett
did you did you know him and he was
actually and characters coming and you
know because social media you know it
just seemed like he was genuine you know
I just love that about him there was no
politics you know I can call him on the
phone and we could get something done
just like that it wasn't a matter of
let's go to speak to my shooter talk to
my team you know ten years basically yes
I'll be there you know and you know this
is you know that story should again
inspire youth a loss because you know he
had it all you could say in the worldly
life you know because success yet when
you know speak with him you know you
have a famous saying off I mean brother
[Music]
close brother house when he mentioned
that you know you've got these thousand
dollar thongs and glasses and and
basically said they mean nothing more
than a pair of thongs for a you know for
a boy I think you and it should
basically wait rupee you know the you
thought that you know do you want that
life what work are you better was this
you know at the time of death we are
probably all gonna be like howdy bonus
but until that moment comes when you see
that death is coming your way all of a
sudden you become you know did I pray
enough you don't care enough you don't
with the cancer because that gave him a
few years to do what we want to do after
the point of death if you bought our
money away you know pray go through
harsh build massage you with the doggies
you don't need to do what he did anyone
can go right down you can wake up this
morning on the Friday and making tension
that only helped change the world before
I expired and I'm gone and this is a
bonus saurian holy lady inspired so many
people and it'll continue you know if
there's many swords on honey bunny that
they don't get it documented you know if
an ally when we had a personal
discussion he didn't like the attention
he didn't lock the define he told me you
know that I've been doing this for a
while until the documentary that came
out about him being gifted in cancer
just made me famous you know he didn't
like that he wanted to just be humble
which is again the sign of you know he's
winning tensions that he doesn't want
the fame you know unfortunately these
days is some you know rather social
media they get excited and what the fame
and glory
and and that is not a good thing because
it's believing actually there's a lot of
honeyBun ectopia that you do not even
know about you know and what then would
work and never go near a camera because
I don't want in case you know the
intention changes from doing something
good to getting famous you know you know
we're all working that down with you'll
get afraid on that that my intention
doesn't sway who wanted to good for the
girls on a camera wanted to you know be
popular get more likes and I think you
said in using tension 100 times a day
and this is a prophet of Allah so again
who are we so we need to make sure we
know that intention is always is
although narrating the heart Sanjana
Sharma the amazing work and continued
thanks to social media and you know all
the documentaries he's worth continues
so you can continue to support his work
and many others excited to hear that
you're really into nutrition you're
staying away from fake food you're
eating real food tell us a little bit
about that when did you get when did you
get started to take this serious you
take care of and you back any and that's
you know and so we in the you know take
care of it you started uncovering all
the you know all the information about
you know yes great so yeah we've been
talking a lot we've been talking a lot
more of this because it's a it's a
health crisis going on so we've been
trying to get people more aware of you
know of eating healthy and staying away
from fake foods yeah that are killing us
yes
you know in something and drinking
something you know
probably don't answer if you clean up
your you know the food you're eating
everything that you're doing as many
there are many cases out there with
people are actually cured or reverse and
cancer just by changing the daughter's
so through you know investigating and
looking for more and more I realize that
the water that we're drinking every
single day processed foods even the food
that's you know the fruit [ __ ] even
that you know needs cleaned up you know
so many stop discovering all of these
things you realize look at all the
leaves on you know the rhythms and we're
getting to see as soon as I cut sugar
out of mine my food and your son had
most whole food and so I started cooking
everything eating it and junk food and
home did he let the burqa look for the
last three or four years we have mercy
once I'm hungry yeah my hay fever went a
lot of the massage you said I think it's
a routine every month or so you need
taking you travel to the doctor with the
ear infection or throat infection or
runny nose they're not easy sending more
in my household Honolulu off course but
again even as common sense you know to
see that look this information this is
bad this causes cancer he's you know
he's gonna make you sink or kill and by
reversing you know my wife's on and
eating more son wonders for me I don't
even know what doctors surgery looks
like anymore medicine it's a sake what
they do is basically pump you the food
that makes you see and send you off to
the doctor he pumps you up with the the
drugs that temporarily make you be there
you come back to the food it's a song
that doesn't in weight cycle is why you
know put into your hearts voice it
probably a little bit difficult at the
beginning but you should be strong but
you feel the result straightaway and
it's going back you know why don't you
cross to the other side of will eating
and being as a day you know almost on
Thailand has this something to help you
know on fire before far as you know you
know before the holidays and to to
basically you know keep that government
for a long time yet you help because you
need that to Darwin to travel learn to
crane and satellite anomalies you need
your body so you know that's very messy
as well as much awareness but it's
slowly coming out now yeah we've been
trying to create awareness of this we
have several shows one of them people
can watch on the YouTube is called sick
and tired of being sick and tired with
one of the top nutritionists in the
country Jim Marlow and we've been
talking about this we also had a
holistic doctor dr. Medina Sayed Medina
on the program and others were also
pioneers out there who are spreading the
message and trying to get the Muslims to
wake up to start eating real food and in
voiding fake food that's the message eat
real food
that's the TE bot that a la small notes
loss want Allah talks about and all this
processed junk that's actually much of
it is if not most of it is causing the
cancers and heart disease and the
diabetes and like you mentioned these
things are reversible when you make food
your medicine and medicine your food and
yeah and that's one of the things that I
actually went to war on first was that
sugar sugar is the new nicotine of our
times and replacing it replacing it with
you know dates or bananas apples with
the real food and cutting out this and
it's a simple it's it's simple it takes
some effort but trying to create that
awareness in the mush kids when you come
out and they got the Pepsi and the colas
and the and the potato chips and you're
killing the kids and I think have you
done anything will get into this now
we're with Zaki
where Zaki star
educate the the kids and the adults on
eating real food have you done anything
on food just a quick brief on how that
happened was you know looking at 27
productions and our you know it yourself
it's sometimes difficult to work with
the youth you know because sometimes
they're conditioned to be a certain way
and for me I I just got frustrated you
know trying to give to the youth help
them change their ways so I just thought
you know the only way we're going to
change this rumor is by sorry planting
the seeds and that's really kids so
through that kinda Louis me so once the
kids aqui who hundred eyes very
well-known reward now and part of not it
wasn't about teaching them good and
teaching a menace
because you know youth could be a
hospital typical end you could be you
know you could memorize the entire book
but if you have no man's sake if you
have no character if you know if you're
a daddy but you go home and treat your
wife and kids bad then get me really
what has always benefited you so I
thought for me with children we focused
mostly on manners character you know
these are the things I've been to almost
missing and now that like I said I've
gotten into the nutrition you know we we
always if we do go to events are
actually advise them down so soft drinks
to the kids replace like you said you
know the lobbies and all the rest of it
you know you can you can make fruit
salad you can this day since so many
things that got natural sweetness the
honey's that you don't need all these
stuff so we do have two characters
coming out called Harun and Russia and
they do have two segments on Jackie's
own Club
that focus on nothing about health and
you know that's probably an area we
found that now with the entertainment
world just going nuts you know there's
so much goodness and
a lot of Filth on Lord the kids that we
thought we should target that area in
not just if semi teachings but also here
health because you know being healthy
also makes you build something people
don't realize you know would be a lot
easier if we ate better if we intercept
all night once you move these and on
each and then you know shopping that
food down our body and then we realized
yeah chef what kind of getup full
version body you know and on the health
I think you've probably heard now the
fire scene is a big thing now huge messy
and you find that all these
professionals come out me you know
different types of doors he saw it works
at door it works and it's a problem they
went around and came back to we would
use it a lot this fast you know and
don't be extravagant you know because
that's one of the things I think now
that food is so tasty
you know just anything tastes wound that
you you're not even hungry you know you
just came from a dinner and somebody's
house and you're driving and you saw the
little Donald's and just grab something
because you know it's an addiction it's
not you're not eating to live you live
in to eat now that's the problem with
the world today so you know you don't
you can't eat that sweet anymore whether
it's a lemonade sweet or you know sweet
you know try things don't experiment a
bit more not you could say conditioned
and sit so that was inspiration to yeah
people don't understand that the adults
are projecting their food preferences on
the kids so now the kids don't know any
better and they're destroying their
taste buds and now they're you're
creating sugar addicts and now we got
kids who are diabetic at nine ten years
old and teeth that are made to last a
lifetime
kids are getting root canals
and they're destroying their teeth their
health and nobody is linking it back
well most of the people are not linking
it back to what's in their covers in
their fridge and simple adjustments
avoid get rid of the fake food and put
the real food in the fridge and the real
food is food that doesn't come with a
list of ingredients that you can't
pronounce you need a PhD in chemistry to
pronounce so I'm very excited before we
conclude I personally I I think I bought
all of the zacky's for my kids I'm a
huge fan of your guys work I think if
you're not if you're not down with one
Islam you're not down because I mean you
this is something that is so your
production is top of the line you guys
are doing incredible work now you have a
new app that people can go on it's
called one for kids one for kids I got
it
it's amazing talk to us about this look
which we do the only problem is you know
what kids that open after 10 years but
we have been struggling financially for
so so long and we still are because you
know solution net1 could keep these huge
studio the millionaires in there well I
have to this exact opposite when you see
our work yes
we work 18 hours a day sometimes to get
that out to you because a production
that costs $50,000 we hadn't fraction of
the price because I basically write the
scripts my innards I'll do a lot of the
voices which you're looking at the voice
exactly myself I'll do the voices of
Tesla I'll do the voice of the two or
three hundred characters because it's
almost to pay for all that we will be
sitting here talking about one of the
kids it wouldn't exist so the hard work
we're putting in is what's keeping what
the kids and the sake entertainment that
we learn alive so this is one thing that
sometimes success you know becomes where
the authority that Wow
well those brothers it's the opposite
one of the reasons we decided 130 TV app
was to get the Muslims to you know three
ninety-nine a month is I think you could
I don't know the the process of a coffee
in Chicago there Eddie but you know it's
almost a cup of coffee price a month
that yeah all of our content it's a down
Amazon Roku Apple Android everything and
everything the best part of that three
line line they're paying you can't lose
so you're getting access to constant you
know entertainment for your kids
wherever they are you can hand the phone
to them you know Safe Browsing all that
content contains no music you know
coming from a formal musician I know the
effective music so hundred and out run
lots of songs again but it's all harmony
bass or voice nothing else and Pablo is
the only channel in the world to have a
channel that's 100 percent hello our
content is pure and allure and as best
as we can and yes available and and
people need to really subscribe you know
we don't have nowhere near the amount of
subscribers need to take on the Disney's
you know we really need twenty thirty
thousand subscribers to help us get to
that level and produce much better
content but you know as a father that's
you know answers what are they did
almost a time on devices you know as
parents you try to control it but it
comes probably miss that breaking you
like he the phone but knowing that you
know we know we need content you know
content cost a lot of money and you know
this is we're asking the Muslims to you
know because wealthy
brothers and sisters you normally get
that response so we have two demands
that there's a grandfather's uncle's who
are concerned about all my and in Keith
and what we're watching and will tell me
subscribe you know tell me what keeps
older now I don't need it really
so the kids are getting married soon in
charlotte and their records so it's what
is one you cannot escape it
you're very far they've got grandkids if
you keep the whole drama you know if you
know if you're not married you know
so there's a way and if none of those
you want good for them so you could all
watch Disney and all these other things
that is slowly introducing their
homosexuality engineered their movies
things like the movie frozen which is
extremely popular among some girls is
rumored to have the main character a
lesbian in Part two coming out Netflix
and reducing transgender cartoons so
they are really pushing this into turn
now
you know anything visiting in immediate
species for our kids it's going to be
too late you know I mean hum do learn
you find a massage you are being built
everywhere you know but you're walking
in the empty and it's on a friary day
there's no using it kids I mean it where
are the kids
the must use now that that depositing
their handle dough so we need to now
provide that and entertainment but at
the same time clean their house watching
something inspires them to do something
good show more and we get so many emails
idiot
it's basic you could send with a fuel
because I have been the fund every week
you got to find ways to get funding and
the fuel that keeps you going
he's just a feedback you know some
children that they grow up become
teenagers and you know sometimes we get
hug from behind from a teenager Scott
and it needs like remember me you came
to my school moves a key in because of
that I went to after that which is
Martinez tiny and this apana bleeding a
lot of ways but because of your
involvement in our films you know become
a scholar and now you're teaching piece
so I'm saying that sort of is area the
people that are packed
subscription this once I would he's gone
back to educating these kids and these
kids are gonna some of them will be
future machines and teachers Junior we
really encourage people to subscribe at
the moment not one rated you can go on
the Apple or Google soon with the
hardest reading app in the world a
hundred left channel and no music so
brothers don't be concerned yes is lot
of response but no musical hum doing
there and soon will be will be down your
way so we'll have you and Zaki and
she'll on the studio soon so that's one
that's one that's one for kids TV
that's so for them to on the Android or
on the iPhone they just go to the App
Store and they type in one for kids TV
and no excuse no no if you've got if you
if you got the Netflix you got the face
but YouTube and many of these you know
they just take one wrong turn and
they're getting poison subliminal
messages and whatnot but here is is
where you're educating the kids and not
just the kids I mean new Muslims adults
I mean the information there is not just
for kids everyone can benefit even an
adult this is a great way because it's
so simple and straightforward a lot of
people you know they can't sit there and
and maybe listen to a monotone let
sheriff from someone but they can go and
learn from this app from the material
you guys got adult awesome
you know and please tell me you know one
for the kids to do Zach in Sydney and he
said why and my mother's computer once
probably nineties and he said brother
these lives have changed my life changed
my
families like the film's in making and
and and yeah so when he came back and
Tommy that story and eating smiley some
us on Iran because to know people all
around the world adults especially
rebirth because you know our productions
Apple kids but when a convert or Aretha
comes to Sam you know he's the same
acknowledge is back to basics so they
need to learn that era be they need to
learn the numbers they need to learn the
short straws and explanations and this
is perfect for them so lucky since you
know kids are watching
but secretly parents are working going I
didn't know that either
you know tell me brother
much more than my teens because you know
these same schools now kids do have a
lot of education but you know the
parents need to catch up to their kids
now because even access producers and
writers when we're writing these scripts
we sit back and think wow you know this
is an amazing story this happened
so yeah it's to everyone as we said
please subscribe 399 you know it's it's
it's a packet of the you know chips
which is nothing and you can't you can't
news you know thank you my brother
Sophie was really nice having you on the
program inshallah we're gonna hook up
soon when you come to Chicago
how's that sound all right just Dhokla
hi thank you brother
what an amazing story with Sophie I hope
that that got to resonate and penetrate
deep into your hearts so many lessons to
be learned
he almost signed in the dotted line
imagine where that would have took him
in life but he committed himself to the
Dean he didn't sell out and he became a
winner and insha'Allah those who hold
onto the deem it can be hard an arduous
task hole
as the prophet saw some said that he'll
come a time we're holding on to the Dean
will be like holding on trying to hold
on to some hot coals you feel like a
stranger in the mists of all of the
corruption that's out there but the last
and final messenger sent to mankind
problem and peace and blessing be upon
him said he said what give glad tidings
to the strangers paradise Jenna awaits
you by living purpose committing
yourself to pleasing your Creator before
we meet our Creator so those few minutes
because what is life but a few minutes
at the end when it's all done and said
look how fast everything's in the past
past tense been there done that
and that's how life is gonna be you've
been there you've done that you
sacrifice everything for this dunya and
you didn't prepare for what comes next
but our brothers preparing for what
comes next and it's an inspiration or
motivation for us to take the matter
serious to take life serious and not to
get caught up with all of the
entertainment that's out there it's a
delusion a deception but we've been
gifted with this Deen we have the
blueprint for life stick to it and
Jenna's yours you want Jenna
so do I so let's continue with the
mission to please our Creator by living
this Deen and inshallah we can make it
and everything that Allah calls us to do
is beneficial not only for us but for
mankind - so you get peace in your life
peace in the next but don't lose focus
don't sell out don't SOT sign away your
soul give your soul away for the dunya
don't do it because you'll be a loser at
the end and then sha Allah this story
can teach us a lot to stay committed to
something that's worth more than
anything money can buy or give us this
Deen stick to it hold to it and
inshallah we can get to Jenna subscribe
if you haven't to the Deen show and
we'll see you next time hit on those
little notification
so you can get with each and every one
of our new shows peace be with you
sanam like please subscribe to the diva
follow us on our official Facebook and
Twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below
[Music]